right so as a in my my relationship I  want your time if you felt like you  couldn't give your partner adequate time  and you know that's the only thing she  wants from you would you feel like you  need to terminate the relationship no  because I'm married with a child yeah  it's way higher than that so I think and  this is what we talk about and why I ask  a question about modern women and  selfishness I truly believe that when we  in the relationship it's not about me no  more so whatever it is that I need to  sacrifice to make sure this thing works  is what I have to sacrifice that's my  responsibility as a person who's brought  a child into this world  right